jerry lewis et beaucoup de tomber nous
fait le lot
jusqu'au jour où le 20 mars 1965
jerry lewis explose deux vertèbres dans
le bas de la colonne vertébrale en
atterrissant sur un câble métallique et
à deux millimètres près votre colonne
vertébrale était foutu il a été paralysé
pendant 27 heures sa venue à gué dargaud
band pendant 37 ans pour sortir du lit
vous montrez ways to
à
police avait nié à l'écouté des figures
on vous donne des pilules et vous
devenez accro aux antidouleurs et au
perco dans à cette époque là vous
devenez un toxicomane bien ce bien ce
que vous ne travaillez pas vous êtes
assis sans but 20 1 et à l'époque vous
avez des ulcères à l'estomac à cause de
l'abus de médicaments des antilles des
ongles longs et là vous envisagé le
suicide comme une délivrance
yes un jour il allait revolver il a
voulu se flinguer alias eddie djemai
d'autres il a entendu sa fille si c'est
dan et wê yu dehui s'appelait je dis
papa qu'est ce que tu fais tiger woods
et nikos a young man show il avait un
pistolet dans son show et il a dit à sa
fille qu'il est en train de répéter
en fait il voulait vraiment se suicider
et là effectivement vous avez trouvé un
système qui s'appelle la
neurostimulation alors ces deux
électrodes qu'on met sur la colonne
vertébrale
1 et puis à l'intérieur de l'abdomen
vous avez un petit pays mais coeur dans
le ventre et vous avez une télécommande
alors ce qui est extraordinaire c'est
qu'avec sa télécommande quand il a mal
il règle son pacemaker qui envoie des
ondes sur les deux électrodes qui sont
sur la colonne vertébrale et lavinia
routine à 12
le nexus one thing
les élections n'ont pas très bien
là vous êtes en train de stimuler le
public heures que vous avez dans le
ventre
oui on a nos pays nos paies ait des
notes
but in one et two hours in fine idéaux
voilà donc il est obligé de temps en
temps comme ça de redémarrer son
pacemaker qui travaille sur les
électrodes qui sont sur la colonne
vertébrale
il ya combien de temps que vous avez ça
juillet deux ans à wanted day's night
with the exact
ah ouais le 21 avril ça fera deux ans
exactement oui il utilise à et pourquoi
vous n'avez pas utilisé avant i did now
back ne savais pas que ça existait many
people do not know about the disease
il dit que la douleur chronique est une
maladie silencieuse
oui un pipeau internat ou one 6 un
sixième de la population française
inscrit à dému d'aucune douleur
chronique seventeen éoliennes friendship
au 17 mai dès ce week-end en amérique
ben oui dis que c'est pas seulement en
irak mais c'est de l'espoir
oui oui oui nous on n'a pas ça en france
oui britten je ne sais pas et je et
doctor climatologues
vous connaissez la neurostimulation
n'aurais je ne connais pas la
neurostimulation pour une raison d'abord
c'est que là le la la prise en compte de
la douleur c'est quand même assez récent
ça date d'à peu près une dizaine
d'années après le combat de deux mètres
ça y'a comme françois bourreau ça ne
s'invente pas qui s'est battu françois
braud qui s'est battu pour faire
reconnaître cette douleur faut savoir
que notamment sur les prescriptions de
morphiniques il a fallu vraiment le
combat de bernard kouchner d'autres
ministres de la santé pour que ça passe
et ça a été difficile
like many d'arc
ce docteur comme beaucoup de docteurs
aux états unis ne connaît pas la
neurostimulation bicross et des zones et
roanne qui use haut parce que ça n'a que
20 ans d'existence du dj et dans la
technologie d'aujourd'hui 3,19 five
minutes 20 ans c'est comme ça beginning
darkness
ou quand vous avez cette fleur là oh my
châu bicross hybrid frêne ou un blog
paris match il a amené avec lui un ami
qu'il aime beaucoup couru soin de best
comédie friends amenant qui est un des
meilleurs comiques français avoir tout
aussi à gauche et moi 2000 and see you
rien n'était acté